ماسك لا تنتهي لكنها هذه المره مختلفه عن
كل ما سبق انها الحرب مع ابل اكبر شركه في
العالم من حيث القيمه السوقيه
ابل بانها تهدده ومنشطه بطريقتين الاولى
هي وقف اعلاناتها على تويتر التي تصل الى
100 مليون دولار سنويا بحسب بلند والثانيه
وهي الاخطر احتمال الغاء تطبيق تويتر
عبر الموقع الالكتروني وليس عبر التطبيق
وذلك
كامله بدلا من ان تدفع 30% من هذه الرسوم
واما اعلان الحرب هذه المعركه تذكروا
بخلاف سابق بين ابل وشركه ابل جيمز على
اشتراكات في تطبيق بلاي ستيشن المفارقه ان
ماسك فتح حرب ايضا على جوجل لنفس السبب
واتهامها مع ابل بالاحتكار الثنائي
مستخدما تعبير جيبولي وهدد باطلاقه هاتف
تسلا لكسر احتكار نظامي اندرويد واي يو اس
وللمعركه ايضا خلفيه تونسيه مع اعاده ماسك
ترامب تويتر خطوه استفادت شركات
التكنولوجيا التي سبق ان حضرت الرئيس
الامريكي السابق
المدير المسؤول عن تطبيقات ابل الغي حسابه
تويتر الكهرباء